all right let's move on now to the
southern nevada water authority the
sponsors of the next segment is back to
remind you about winter water
restrictions take a look
[Music]
i'm diana diaz with the southern nevada
water authority and we are here to
remind you that the mandatory winter
watering restrictions are officially in
effect now through the end of february
that means that you can only water on
your one assigned day per week if you
don't know your watering day you can
visit snwa.com put in your address and
you'll get your exact watering day it's
important that you change your watering
clock now to comply with the seasonal
watering restrictions to avoid hefty
water waste fines
watering outside of your assigned
watering days allowing water to spray or
flow off your property is considered
waterways and can result in a fine
fines that are about eighty dollars and
can double there after
now if you want to save up to three
hundred dollars annually on your water
bill
you need to follow the seasonal
mandatory watering restrictions year
round change your watering clock four
times every year so if you haven't
changed your watering clog go out now to
your watering clock and change it to
your one assigned day per week we have
some good watering tips that can help
you maintain a healthy landscape during
winter we recommend that you preferably
water in the mid-morning to avoid your
grass from freezing due to the low
temperatures also if you have sprinklers
water no more than 12 minutes per
watering day that's all your grass needs
you can schedule your irrigation in
three short cycles about four minutes
each with about an hour apart and also
you know invest in a smart controller
the water authority has rebates for
smart controllers and if you invest in a
smart controller you can you know take
advantage of how easy it is to set your
watering clock from anywhere from your
smartphone some great money and water
saving tips include report water waste
to your water provider anytime you see
it also if you have grass that you don't
use useless grass
upgrade it to a water efficient
landscape and we will pay you up to
three dollars per square foot cash
incentive when you participate in our
water smart landscape program and also
if you visit our website snwa.com we
have lots of great resources tools and
rebates and coupons available for you to
take advantage and conserve water
thank you to the southern nevada water
authority for sponsoring that segment
give them a call at
702-258-save or visit snwa.com for more
information we'll be right back right
here on